There had been quite a buzz at the SCP Foundation
when, only a few days ago, word had spread
of a possibly anomalous archaeological dig.
Excavations at a redacted location in the
Middle East had unearthed what appeared to
be an ancient shrine, with a large stone tablet
as its centerpiece, inscribed with runes of
a language lost to the ages.
Now, normally, this wouldn’t be nearly enough
to attract the interest of the Foundation,
especially without any overtly anomalous component
to the shrine.
Usually, this would pass unnoticed as just
a slightly interesting discovery that could
perhaps make its way to a museum.
But along with the tablet were a pair of carvings
on the surface of the stone shrine.
These depicted a pair of figures, seemingly
rivals that were locked together in an endless
cycle of conflict.
And that was what caught the collective eye
of the Foundation: the figures in these carvings
seemed to bear a very close, almost uncanny
resemblance to SCP-073 and SCP-076, better
known respectively as Cain and Able.
While the carvings were too large to be transported
in their entirety, the stone tablet bearing
its inscription was requisitioned by the SCP
Foundation.
And almost immediately after it arrived, the
buzz surrounding it died down, focus shifting
to one of what was considered the far bolder
and more exciting anomalies.
But one researcher – by the name of Isaac
Graves – remained solely focused on the
mysterious tablet.
Researcher Graves was determined to be the
one who discovered the connection between
this stone and both SCP-073 and SCP-076.
Many had long suspected that this pair of
anomalous immortals were related, brothers
even.
Perhaps this tablet and the shrine it was
found in held the key to proving once and
for all if that long-standing theory was indeed
true.
Of course, the biggest obstacle standing in
Graves’ way was: nobody knew how to read
what had been inscribed on the tablet.
The language was runic, and so many thousands
of years old that there was no way of translating
it… or at least, no quick way.
Understanding what was written on the stone
was going to take some time.
Several years of tireless research passed,
with every day Researcher Graves spent studying
the tablet feeling like a step closer to revealing
its secrets.
He had to become fluent in all the languages
spoken in the region where the shrine was
first discovered, along with all the variations
and dialects of each.
Then, it was a case of working backwards,
finding the ancient roots of each of these
modern patterns of speech and writing.
And eventually, after at last discovering
the right linguistic branch, going through
the inscription word by word to translate
it.
It was only when he stepped back, and read
the tablet in its entirety, that Graves understood
what he was truly looking at.
Realization dawning on him, the researcher
turned and barrelled through the facility
corridors.
He demanded to speak urgently with the Site
Director, the Senior Research staff, and anyone
and everyone in authority who would listen.
And all because what Researcher Graves had
found could render all prior study of two
prolific anomalies completely null and void.
He believed that the tablet described the
true, tragic origin of both Cain and Able.
As Graves gathered his various superiors,
he recounted what he had learned from the
tablet.
Years and years ago, many millennia before
the dawn of modern civilization, there had
lived an isolated family.
They lived in a small, rural homestead, maintained
a decent amount of farmland, and traded crops
and livestock with traders from a nearby township
in order to survive.
Two sons were eventually born to a mother
and father whose names were forgotten to the
annals of history.
But their sons’ names, however, would not
only live on in legend, but would one day
refer to a pair of anomalous individuals.
Of course, as most of the Foundation higher
up in the room quickly guessed, the two brothers
were named Cain and Able.
Now, according to the legend Researcher Graves
had translated from the tablet, Cain was the
family’s firstborn son, and for a time,
the pride and joy of his mother and father.
As he got older and reached an age where he
was able to, Cain began to help his father
tend the farmland around their home.
Until, one day, Cain’s mother fell pregnant
again, with yet another son.
However, the birth of this new child was fraught
with far more difficulty, and sadly claimed
the life of the boys’ mother.
As his father held his newborn younger brother
in his arms, Cain stood by his mother’s
side as she passed away.
His father named the new child Able, and raised
him as best as he could.
However, the loss of his wife had stricken
him with grief, which took a toll on him as
the years rolled on and Able grew up.
It seemed with every passing day, as the young
boy grew into a man, time had the opposite
effect on his father.
He became frail, unable to farm any longer,
causing Cain to take up maintaining the crops
in his father’s increasing absence.
Until, one day, the father of the two boys
fell ill.
Eventually succumbing to sickness, he too
died, reunited with his wife but leaving the
pair of brothers alone, with only each other.
The final bit of wisdom their father had imparted
to Cain and Able was to trust in the old man
on the hill.
Sure enough, a figure would often appear looking
down at the valley where they lived.
According to their father, this man was the
Creator, the one who had made the world around
them, all the heavens, and every part of the
universe’s majesty.
He could control life and death, every force
of nature only existed and behaved in accordance
with the Creator’s design.
And before his eventual passing, Cain and
Able’s father had told his two sons that,
if they made a small sacrifice to the Creator,
then he would provide for them and watch over
the brothers.
And so, following their father’s wishes,
Cain and Able would regularly make their journey
up the nearby hill, to where the old man resided.
Sometimes he would speak with them, friendly
conversing while the two men made certain
to be as polite as they knew how to be.
They would present the Creator with goats,
sheep, and all manner of livestock that they
kept on their farm; their offering to him
in exchange for plentiful harvests and the
safe passage of their mother and father into
the great beyond.
The Creator would tell either Cain or Able
to kill their offering, alternating between
each of the brothers every time.
According to the stone tablet, back then,
this was in a time before man had learned
how to kill another man, not a single person
had ever murdered another… but that was
soon to change.
As the brothers grew up, Able reaching his
twenties and Cain just slightly older than
that, they continued to work on their homestead.
Cain was still tending to his parent’s land,
farming crops to feed them both and sell at
market.
It was a hard, laborious life, the heat of
an unforgiving sun bearing down on him in
the fields.
Cain loathed it, every day was exhausting,
but he knew if he stopped, then he and his
brother would perish.
Able, meanwhile, saw to the animals, becoming
a shepherd.
In contrast to Cain’s attitude toward farming,
Able seemed to rather enjoy his work, herding
the cattle.
He had a good command over them, they listened
to what he said, and that seemed, at least
to Cain, to make his younger brother’s job
unfairly easier.
There was some disparity between Cain and
Able.
The tablet didn’t state what had started
it; maybe it was simply the fact they stuck
so unmovably to their roles rather than alternating.
Or perhaps it was a lingering resentment on
Cain’s part; after all, their mother had
died giving birth to Able, which could have
easily led to the older brother laying the
blame at his sibling’s feet.
Even more so as losing his wife had been the
thing that started their father’s eventual
decline, causing him to die too.
But all was as the Creator willed it, Cain
told himself, although it did little to ease
the pain of his parents’ deaths… and did
little to stop what would happen next.
Having grown jealous of his younger brother,
watching him enjoy his work herding the animals
and getting to rest for most of the day while
he slaved away, Cain decided to bring his
own sacrifice to the Creator.
While Able readied a goat to be offered, much
like they had done numerous times before,
Cain gathered up the best of his crops from
the season, and the pair made their journey
up the hill.
Presenting the elderly man with both their
offerings, he seemed confused as to why there
was more this time.
It may have been that the Creator interpreted
this as greed on the brothers’ part, bringing
him a greater offering in exchange for greater
reward.
Or possibly just out of preference for the
type of sacrifice he accepted.
But whatever the reason, the Creator seemed
to favor Able’s offering of the goat over
the crops Cain had presented.
The long walk back down into the valley was
tense, both brothers were silent.
But it was clear to Able that something was
wrong with Cain.
He was seething, practically shaking with
anger.
Although the younger of the two could never
have predicted what his sibling would do next…
or that he’d never make it to the bottom
of the hill.
In a blind fit of rage, Cain lunged at his
brother, attacking him out of spite at the
fact his sacrifice had been favored.
In his hands, Able still held the blade used
to sacrifice his livestock to the Creator,
until Cain struck him.
The knife clattered to the ground, only for
the elder of the brothers to reach for it.
Completely overwrought with his anger, all
Cain could think was to do unto Able as they
had done to their other sacrifices, maybe
then the Creator would favor him instead of
his younger sibling.
The wise old man was initially horrified to
see Cain returning so soon, carrying the body
of Able over his shoulders which he then dumped
at the Creator’s feet.
No one on Earth had ever killed a fellow human
being before, this was completely unprecedented.
It was only when he saw the saddened look
in the old man’s eyes and his brother’s
corpse lying still on the ground that the
true gravity of what he had done hit Cain.
He pleaded with the Creator to reverse what
he’d done, saying over and over again that
he had made a mistake.
The old man agreed to oblige, perhaps knowing
or just believing that Cain hadn’t wanted
to kill Able.
Controlling the forces of life and death itself,
he resurrected the younger of the brothers,
and in the process, turned him into a mighty
warrior, with an inexhaustible supply of weaponry
so that he would never be slain again and
could always defend himself from harm.
However, the same rage that had possessed
Cain now took hold of Able.
With his newfound power, he immediately went
to exact a terrible, brutal vengeance on his
brother.
Witnessing the ferocity of the younger man,
and the horrible wounds Able inflicted on
Cain, the Creator was forced to intervene.
As he had done before, he returned Cain to
life and repaired the damage to his body,
but saw it fit to punish both the brothers
for what they had done out of jealousy, anger,
and revenge.
The old man deemed it so that neither one
of them could die; Able would fall but return
to life each time.
Meanwhile, the Creator condemned Cain to wander
the Earth forever, but the man who had once
farmed and made the land fertile for crops
would never again get to witness the majesty
of nature.
Wherever he went, the plants around Cain would
wither and die, while any wound that was inflicted
upon him would be reflected back on the one
who caused it, as a constant reminder of the
harm he had done to his little brother, Able,
and thus started all this.
After telling the legend in its entirety,
Researcher Graves led the Site Director and
Senior Researchers back to his lab where he
had been studying the stone tablet.
They arrived just in time to see it crumbling
into dust, destroying all records of what
Graves had learned about SCP-073 and SCP-076.
The tragic story of how Cain and Able came
to be was lost forever.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go and check out “SCP-073 - Cain”
and “SCP-076 - Able” for more of these
ill-fated immortal brothers!